are there people you regret trusting if
so who
i regret trusting
britney
and
i regret trusting
kyle
yeah i don't want to talk a lot about
them because i don't want to ask them to
have
space on my life for now
now that you've had time to sit with it
what do you think of michael's goodbye
message you seem shocked at the time
so i kind of called that alliance when
monty was an hoh and
he told me there was not a thing and
i kind of let it go but
i was shocked that i knew it and i
couldn't
you know do anything about it and
it is what it is it is a game and people
make alliances and i'm i'm more mostly
surprised that my friends chose to make
an alliance with people that they don't
get along instead of making alliance
with me that's pretty much what i am at
right now
it seems like you didn't like taylor why
was that and do you wish you had
approached that relationship differently
okay
there was never a thing about not liking
taylor
and i hope you guys really can see that
you guys can go back and see the
the episodes i don't know like how much
they cut like how how was added but
being a house with 15 different people
24 7.
sometimes you're going to connect with
people in a week sometimes you're going
to connect with people in three weeks
then sometimes you're never gonna
connect with people
and i never say that i don't like taylor
i say that i didn't connect with her the
first week
and even that i always defended her i
always had her back i was like try to
protect her and i always try to be
honest with her since week one
first week when daniel put her on the
blog and i knew that she was going home
with like 12 votes i had like a really
bad morning i cried all day and i was
like daniel i'm not
pulling her out because i don't want
anyone to go home in the first week
with 12 votes i don't think that's okay
and i would feel so bad
that was
that that would happen with me and i
hope you guys see that i really do hope
that you guys see that
so
and she knows that and she feels that
way we talked a lot during
these past weeks and
her feedback to me was always like i
love you so much because you were always
honest with me and i know you always had
my back even if you were not really
close so i hope you guys see that and i
really hope that
i don't get this
question anymore you know because
uh of course you're gonna connect with
people in a different stage in a
different way but that doesn't mean that
i don't like
her at all and it's literally the
opposite i really believe they put us in
the game to play together unfortunately
i didn't notice i gave myself
opportunity like to know other people
that was like that i got close like and
i got trapped in the game but at this
last week even if i left the house on
her hoh
that i think we had the best week as a
friend and we had like a really good
connection i finally could feel like her
love towards me and i hope she felt my
love towards her as well i left the
house adoring her i really think that
she's amazing and
i hope i don't get
this type of questions anymore
because that's not the truth
now you said when you left that
the house guests would regret evicting
you
who do you think will end up regretting
it the most
i believe my friends like monty
michael joseph
i think at the end of the day
you should choose to play with people
that you love that you
one
that you want to have by dance you know
and
seeing that they are choosing people
that they don't really get along to play
with
it's kind of sad and sad for them
because i'm really loyal
i'm super honest and
i believe that
i would play this game in a happy way
you know
and
giving my best my best self as always so
i think they
at some point they're gonna feel that
now last question what surprised you the
most about playing big brother
oh my gosh it surprised me that
people really
like put the price tags on them
on themselves and surprised me that
no matter what happened
i am still happy
about who i am
so
at some points i felt that i would be
different or i knew just
go with the majority or are you just
like be too emotional and etc
and i think i
i am pretty mature
i'm so i'm at my heart like i'm going
home like i'm going to the jury house
right now like really proud of who i was
in the game
and
it surprised me that i was able to be
myself and
to do the best that i could at the
moment and
keep peace you know inside of me and
outside of me i think everyone could see
oh
indy is inside of the house and outside
of the house and i'm really proud about
it i don't know how america feels about
me how canada feels about me
how the world feels about me
but i'm impressed about who i am and
surprised me that i could even if in
this crazy game
the like people like just go crazy i was
still myself
you